[Música]
estimados maestros y maestras en este
vídeo tutorial descubriremos cómo ubicar
los contenidos mediante el buscador de
khan academy
empecemos ingresando nuestro usuario y
contraseña en la plataforma una vez
dentro ubicaremos en la parte superior
la opción buscar debemos digitar el tema
que deseamos encontrar mientras vayamos
digitando irán apareciendo algunas
palabras de interés facilitando nuestra
búsqueda una vez digitado el tema
existen dos posibilidades 1 encontrar el
tema como tal por ejemplo razones
trigonométricas identificamos qué tipo
de contenido es si es vídeo práctica o
artículo se recomienda hacer clic a
cualquier opción esto nos llevará al
conjunto de contenidos que posee en la
plataforma relacionada a este tema en la
parte izquierda observamos todo el
paquete de contenidos que posee un ese
tema y su ruta de ubicación curso
geometría unidad triángulos rectángulos
y trigonometría lección introducción a
la razón es trigo numérico
2 el contenido digital no aparece
exactamente por lo que debemos
seleccionar un nombre relacionado y
ubicarlo mediante la ruta por ejemplo
digitando área de cuadrados no aparece
con ese nombre
por lo que buscando área de rectángulos
damos clic y en la práctica
efectivamente verificamos que algunos
ejercicios pertenecen al tema buscado
una vez identificado el tema procedemos
a seleccionar los contenidos necesitados
ya sean artículos vídeos o prácticas y
sus respectivos enlaces para el trabajo
a realizar al encontrar el contenido
podemos utilizar todas las opciones
según necesidad de nuestro trabajo
recordemos que el buscador es una gran
herramienta para encontrar contenidos y
muy utilizada por los maestros y
diferentes usuarios de khan academy les
recordamos que es la familiarización con
la plataforma y las herramientas de khan
academy es un proceso que dependerá del
tiempo que le dediquemos y que estamos
seguros que lo lograrán rápidamente nos
vemos